vice president kamala harris is taking
on the lead
as joe biden's border boss essentially
just days after laughing in the face of
a reporter who pressed her on
when's she gonna go look
do you plan to visit the border
not today
[Laughter]
well but that's now her boss so with joe
biden passing the buck what can we
expect to happen at the border let's
talk to
retired acting ice director and fox news
contributor
tom homan tom good morning to you good
morning
okay we know she was the attorney
general from the uh
sanctuary state of california but what
else do we know about how she regards
our southern border when president biden
says she's most qualified
i i mean i mean seriously i mean what
you know
what color is this guy in his world
because you couldn't do that you
couldn't get a worse pig look she
supports sanctuary cities
she wrote legislation to reward those
who are illegal in the united states
she vilified the men and women of the
border patrol during last season of
mistreating immigrants
she she's she's an open borders advocate
she wants to abolish ice she compared
immigration officers to the kkk
during a senate hearing and you want to
put her in charge
of immigration enforcement on the border
i couldn't think of a worse choice
well and because in 2019 she supported
decriminalizing
uh crossing the border illegally it's
it's a federal
violation of statute and yet she was
saying you know what
that shouldn't probably be against the
law
well it's the most qualified person to
fix this issue how about the
how about the chief of the united states
border patrol who's a great guy he spent
his whole career on the border he could
fix this
if you give him the power to change the
policies that need to be changed
and let him do his job that's the guy
you know he it's not some politician but
you know one of the first things
they say kamal is going to do is travel
to mexico travel central america talk to
them folks
why don't you just sit down and talk to
the commander of the border patrol
ask him their opinion they've been
through this before they know how to fix
this
the same way president trump picked it
if they resist all they got to do is one
thing if joe biden said today
i'm going to reestablish remain in
mexico program effective immediately
border crossings will go down 75 percent
in the 24-hour period
yeah that's a good point you know when
you look at
president trump it was about a year ago
he put mike pence in charge of the
coronavirus response
essentially joe biden is admitting okay
this is a crisis so i'm going to put my
number two
in charge of this but there is political
peril for her
because if it does not work out well
this could actually damage her
presidential ambitions
it is not going to work out well i'll
tell you that right now and joe biden
should you know look
he's already said he wants to have
agreements with these countries he had
there were agreements with these
countries
agreements honduras el salvador
guatemala mexico
and they destroyed them all in two weeks
if they would have stuck to the trump
play but
joe biden could have the most secure
border in our country if he would have
just built upon the success of president
trump
but they tore everything down trump and
this is what they got today again
not by accident not by incompetence but
by design
this is what open borders looked like
and joe biden to win an election
sold out to progressive left to get an
open border he knew exactly what he was
doing and made these promises
before you go i wanted to ask about
yesterday the white house
took a pool reporter on a tour of a
facility i think in corrazo springs
which is it's one of the child
facilities one of the child detention
facilities
uh and it's run by the dhs it's not run
by the border patrol which has been
described as more
jail-like which has been referred to as
kids in cages
and ted cruz said you know real
transparency would have been
rather than to take people there take
him to the donna facility
because it's at 1556 percent capacity
where the kids go to sleep hungry they
sleep on the floor they haven't seen
sunlight in seven days
and it's full of covet why did the white
house
and that's the place i'm talking about
right there in donna texas that they
those are the leaked photos from
congressman cuellar
why didn't the white house take
reporters to that place
rather than you know the the place that
they
essentially are putting on their
brochures because it's run perfectly
because they're not transparent they're
hiding the truth of american people
for the same reason they won't admit
there's a crisis i mean thank god for
you know congressman henry cuellar who
who's been who grew up on that border
leaking them photos because he
he he told the truth the secretary three
days later said well we're going to show
some film and some pictures we're not
ready we're concentrating operations
henry corey released some photos and
when 24 hours they came out with their
pictures all
you know of course showing the facility
all doctored up and and well taken care
of
they're hiding the truth from the
american people and by their fact they
want to admit there's a crisis
with 5 000 crossings a day show they
have no problem at all
hiding the truth from american people
what's really going on down there there
are 16
000 kids in federal custody this morning
all right
tom thank you very much for joining us
live